FOR A NEW MEMBER
HERE AT GIGOLO HOUSE
TO REPLACE HAMMER,
ALL RIGHT?
FIRST CANDIDATE.
LET'S GO!
- BRO, STRAIGHT-UP
MAN-TO-MAN QUESTION:
ARE YOU AN ARCHITECT?
- YES.
- NEXT CANDIDATE!
- YOUR WIFE AND YOU HIRED
PETER TO [bleep]?
- I MEAN, YEAH,
THAT'S A SPIN ON IT, SURE.
- YOU CAN BE, LIKE, A WEIRDO GUY
IN THE CREW.
- FAVORITE
FAST AND THE FURIOUS MOVIE.
- UH, 2 FAST 2 FURIOUS.
- WRONG. FAST FIVE.
NEXT!
- I'M GETTING SILHOUETTE.
- ♪ WHOA, OOH, WHOA
- HI.
I'M FARLEY.
- LET ME ASK YOU A QUESTION,
FARLEY.
- WHAT, BOBBY? WHAT?
- OKAY, FINE,
YOU WANNA START WITH ME
RIGHT NOW
IN FRONT OF EVERYBODY?
- IT'S NOT
ALL ABOUT YOU, BOBBY.
- STUPID, BOBBY.
- THIS IS ABOUT
THIS BEAUTIFUL SPECIMEN
THAT WANTS TO BE
A GIGOLETTE.
- I WANNA BE
A STRAIGHT-UP GIGOLO.
THAT'S WHAT
I'M TALKING ABOUT.
I WANNA BE LIKE
ONE OF YOU.
I GREW UP
WITH MANY BROTHERS.
AND, LIKE, I WATCHED THEM
[bleep] THEIR GIRLFRIENDS
THROUGH A KEYHOLE.
AND I WAS LIKE,
"I KNOW WHAT THEY LIKE
AND I KNOW WHAT MEN NEED."
- BEFORE WE GET ANY FURTHER,
DO YOU HAVE A RESUME FOR US?
- UM, I THINK
I BROUGHT MY RESUME...
- OKAY.
- AND IT'S RIGHT HERE.
- WHERE?
- SO BASICALLY,
IF YOU DON'T SEE A RESUME
IN FRONT OF YOU
RIGHT NOW,
THEN YOU'RE BASICALLY
MAJORLY TRIPPING.
- MANY WOMEN ARE LOOKING
TO LOCK DOWN A HUSBAND,
SOMEBODY REAL, A BOYFRIEND.
ARE YOU LOOKING FOR NOTHING
BUT CASUAL SEX,
A CYCLE OF NONSTOP [bleep]
IN YOUR HOLES?
- I'M COMFORTABLE WITH THAT
VERY MUCH SO.
THERE'S ABSOLUTELY NOBODY
IN MY LIFE
THAT I EVER WOULD HAVE
FEELINGS FOR EVER AGAIN
'CAUSE I'M [bleep]ING DONE
WITH FEELINGS.
- REALLY?
- AND RIGHT NOW,
FROM WHAT I'VE BEEN THROUGH,
I'M BASICALLY LIKE A MACHINE
AT THIS POINT.
- WHAT ARE YOU
TALKING ABOUT?
- UGH, YOU RUIN EVERYTHING
I TRY TO DO.
WHENEVER I TRY
TO MAKE SOMETHING OF MYSELF,
IT'S LIKE YOU'RE RIGHT THERE
TRYING TO CUT ME DOWN.
- I JUST WANNA BUILD YOU UP.
- WHAT?
- BOBBY, NO ONE CAN HEAR YOU
WHEN YOU CRYIN'
90% OF THE TIME.
- I DON'T CRY.
- HE CRIES A LOT.
- NONSTOP.
IT'S LIKE LITTLE BOY BLUE
OR SOME [bleep].
- OKAY, I THINK
WE'VE HEARD ENOUGH.
YOU EMBODY
ALL OF THE ATTRIBUTES
THAT IT TAKES TO BE
A GIGOLO.
SHE IS BEAUTIFUL,
SHE IS INTELLIGENT,
AND SHE IS GOOD TO GO
SEXUALLY.
WELCOME TO GIGOLO HOUSE.
- [giggles]
[applause]
THANK YOU.
- NO, BRO, VETO, BRO.
- SO THEN BOBBY
STARTS SAYING
LIKE WHAT I CAN
AND CANNOT DO
BEIN' THAT I AM A WOMAN.
HOW ABOUT HULLARY CLINTON?
- BRO, IF THERE WEREN'T
A GIGOLO CODE,
I WOULD STRAIGHT-UP
PUNCH YOU IN THE--
- BRO, I DON'T GIVE A [bleep]
ABOUT THE CODE.
I WILL END YOU.
- HOW ABOUT YOU FORGET
THE CODE
AND JUST HIT HIM
IN HIS STUPID FACE?